en région parisienne chez Eddy un jeune
homme extravagant qui partage sa vie
avec sa maman depuis l'âge de 6 ans et
dit ne vit que pour la danse salsa
moderne jazz et hip-hop rythme sa vie et
non plus aucun secret pour lui
dire ça et puis ma façon d'être
beaucoup les gens ça m'ouvre énormément
de portes et j'espère qu'avec ça bah tu
mourir assez fort
[Applaudissements]
le portrait d'Eddy et tu nous avais
parlé tu comptais sorti tu étais une
star et à l'époque tu avais créé une
vraie amitié avec Anaïs vous formiez le
duo des foufounass
pas pourquoi
d'ailleurs celle-ci avait beaucoup
beaucoup pleuré lors de ton élimination
on aurait dit que vous n'alliez pas
regarder
[Musique]
moi
c'est pas réveillé
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je me réveille je travaille je suis je
suis voilà je suis pas très loin
[Applaudissements]
reconnaître un requin gay ça fait
[Musique]
pour un garçon ça serait history et pour
une fille ça serait et story mais une
autre prononciation un garçon history
une fille is Story c'est Dar moi plutôt
chérie non
et du conseil c'est avant tout la ligne
de l'amour de l'amitié et du Conseil te
propose une énorme gamme de conseils
personnalisés
merci mon avis d'avoir été là je vais
voir quand tu veux franchement tu
reviennes voir quand tu veux je te
remercie beaucoup c'est tu devrais faire
[Applaudissements]
avec toi dans ton émission du samedi ah
je te le dis j'aime bien Eddy
mon chéri